hello Kyle how are you oh you know sit
down
I'll harp now did you make the choice
like when you're like no don't worry
about that you go like I'm gonna be an
actor I'm gonna go buy my full Kyle
Harvey name not just kinda think yeah I
feel like when you're actor you kind of
have no choice
or you could come up with a hacker named
you can be like Kyle Kyle I don't know
Kyle Kuzak is a good name though that's
like an easy name to remember that's not
that's not a hard name you know it's not
you it's like crazy I like to to white
first names that's right you can't go
wrong with that Charlemagne's in the
movie and he gets to be credited as
Charlemagne's a god yeah the guy cuz
that is just like I mean that's just
like an a staple brand at one point like
Charlemagne can Charlamagne tha God can
put Charlemagne the guide on like random
[ __ ] like his you know like his doctor's
appointment I started VM a press pass
yesterday said Charlamagne tha God on it
he doesn't even it's probably on his ID
at this but that's what I'm saying yeah
if a cop is like driving you know
driver's license and registration please
he's gonna hand it to him and it's gonna
say Charlamagne tha God right where did
you sit your good seats I think I yes I
think I had really good seats um you
know it's for what I did you know I just
really introduced logic that was like my
only and I was nominated too you know so
you know maybe I could have had better
seats ya know but honestly my seats were
incredible I was right there you know
like the stage kind of like you know
they had the part where they were
talking at and then they had like the
little loop that came out yeah yeah I
was the second row right in front of
that loop well did you we just watched
we're a little choked up I mean we just
watched a really touching tribute that
Madonna did with some reason I had a
picture of Aretha Franklin in the back
and why she talked about everything she
was saying was I you know I mean it was
really fire I'm like okay this is like a
really cool interesting story but have
to do iterate read the Frank yeah that's
right
well Aretha was a also a woman I think
that tighter then she's also a lady I
think that's how it tied in you know
that was I mean them
man I don't know that that's a good one
that was like that is true she's lady
she's well she said at one point she
tried to sing a wreath in an audition
and they didn't think she could but then
luckily Madonna rose above it and that
was important in the Aretha tribute to
hear how Madonna rose above it yeah dude
I felt the same way
and you know I I didn't watch that in
person but when I went back to my hotel
room and was watching it again I was
like what this happened well I like that
finally finally there's somebody on
stage the VMAs they're gonna let you
know the struggles of being a pretty
skinny white woman yeah it was I'm not
lighted it was weird do people hate it I
don't know if other people hated it I
personally I didn't necessarily hate it
cuz like I said like I think listening
to Madonna give a really base the story
is dope like I'm here for that just I
didn't I'm not here for that mixed with
you know we need to pay tribute to
Aretha Franklin right yeah so weird I
think we need to pay tribute to read the
Franklin we should pay tribute to Aretha
Franklin right in a very like
transparent to the point kind of way
yeah I don't think you should play with
that duty and not that Madonna did you
know I think she's based based you know
the definition of based does that mean a
self-centered ass you know just you're
just kind of out there like nothing
right which I think Madonna kind of is
so maybe that's why she did that but
definitely I didn't look at that as
though are you I was like this could be
better right now are you at a point
doing good Madonna but this could be
that this could yeah this could be
different and hey like you said if
Madonna is up there doing a speech about
herself that's fine like you guys have a
tribute yeah but it's like come on this
is a wreath or franklin's moment right
here you should be doing a better job
than telling us about this weird ass
[ __ ] about you who's the boring audition
story I hate that I've auditioned and
bombed for other things it was terrible
I've never made a [ __ ] as an 8-minute
story about you know I'm not gonna
tribute Richard Pryor by telling a story
about me bombing and 1992 yeah so throw
a couple of his jokes and finally you
got some fun
and they were right do you are you at a
point like when you get that famous
there's no one around you who's
everyone's so afraid of being kind of
excommunicated from your inner circle
that nobody will go what the [ __ ] are
you doing stop so when you do a speech
like that and you rehearse it people
like that's great like no one will tell
you do you have people in your life that
will still tell you like hell what do
you do every single person involved in
my life right now
will not only tell me when I'm some [ __ ]
I'm doing is lame but literally go out
of their way to go out of the way to
tell me even when even when some [ __ ]
I'm doing is like semi lame that they
would let another famous person pass
like yeah sure even if it's kind of lame
like my friends are going to let me know
everybody in my circle keeps it a
hundred percent of real with me cuz
that's just like the energy I bring
forth in the beginning like I'm
transparent with people I always ask
people did I [ __ ] up can I do better
like was that wack did I just talk about
an audition that I did when I'm supposed
to be talking about to read the Franklin
right like I want people to keep it real
with me sure man that's like one of the
I guess most important factors for me
and like anybody that's around me is
like don't yes man me the moment you yes
man me it's like that were you [ __ ] up
like we're probably not gonna be friends
anymore did you notice that any of that
started happening when like iSpy became
like you know the huge song they became
I noticed that with like people that
weren't as much of my friend right you
know I mean people that weren't as close
to me as maybe they thought they were
yeah I mean I I have a very small friend
group I always tell people it's funny I
make like I have a hell of acquaintances
but I feel like I make two new friends
like a year and I would say like two
like actual like I this is my friend I
could call this person and just talk to
them mm-hmm about a bunch of random [ __ ]
I make like two a year everybody else is
like we're cool right you know what will
someone do that you're like okay this
guy's gonna remain an acquaintance
because he's just gonna kick my ass and
this guy's a legitimate friend it's
something that they'll tell you that you
might not want to hear yeah you know
what that's what I'm saying I like my my
friends will go out of their way to like
let me know even in like [ __ ] that I
don't really want them to comment on you
know I mean even if it's like me posting
a selfie or some [ __ ] don't Brad that
[ __ ] was terrible you know I mean like
there
and the thing is I'm pretty like you
know I'm okay to laugh for myself I
don't take myself serious enough to like
you know like my ego isn't to this place
where I don't want anybody to poke at it
because it would [ __ ] me up you know
anything like I can exist Wow
being vulnerable I can exist while being
wrong I can exist while being all those
things so it's okay for the people
around me to um you know to call me out
you know I mean I don't I don't feel
like Rick Ross you know Brian but I
don't have like an untouchable ass like
persona does he not like being called
out no I'm not saying that he does but
if I could imagine if I was Rick Ross
he's the boss he's the boss right you
know I mean like he's the boss like you
know who's gonna tell Rick Ross he's
[ __ ] up right yeah it's something to
say about it
so over oh oh yeah there's a big mess
with all this horrifying videos online
oh they were they were saying things to
Rick Ross when were not kind oh [ __ ]
really yeah well it from all different
parts of the country
holy [ __ ] but if anybody can withstand
that and handle that is Rick Ross right
because he's a boss right so how do you
withstand I mean I feel like you don't
really catch it as bad as some other
people do but I feel like people like
there are those obviously your
generation of like rappers super loved
but also super hated Oh like and I feel
like like yachty for example yeah well
yadi takes it probably worse than a lot
of people gets the doors right how do
you guys like kind of not only would
stand that but like push through and
just like now we're gonna keep doing
this weird [ __ ] you know a man the thing
about being young is that you never
you're never like never in the history
of anything has the older generation
accepted what the younger generation is
doing right never like in let's take nas
right golden era hip hop when he was
doing that you I guarantee you the
people who are rapping like 10 years
previously we're like nah man you doing
that [ __ ] too fast man it's bright be
like this yeah I ever it's never been
like I think that's like the whole part
of being young is being misunderstood
and people not you know not being ready
what you're doing and I think it's okay
and the best part of being young is that
when you're young eventually you become
old and do the exact same thing right
and I think that you know I mean in and
of course it's so like it's such an easy
equation to end up like that you know I
mean young people misunderstood old
people feeling entitled that just means
coach working you not me exactly yeah
they put that meet working right right
down like if you didn't have Jim Norton
on the right on a regular basis saying
that hip hop kind of ended after the Fat
Boys stop making began with the Fat Boys
we all know it that should be normal for
me I just want to like bridge you know
I'm saying cuz I like I still love all
that golden hair a rap I grew up on you
know I grew up on that I all my favorite
rappers I ran them just like east coast
old rappers and [ __ ] so I loved all of
that and at the same time like yachties
one of my best friends right sound like
I want to do a good job at trying to
like show people there's no difference
in this you know I mean like obviously
it sounds hella different but you know
old and young need to come together
because hip hop is one of the only
genres where we actually do that though
yeah like rock people kind of do that
but they don't want to end careers like
hip hop older hip hop people would
rather see people like little yachty and
[ __ ] and not exist yes time goes on it
gets more and there's a lot of times
where younger guys I noticed in hip hop
maybe that's changed but they did a lot
of times appreciate the guys before them
it was almost like with with Rocky give
guys that were considered legends but
with rappers it didn't seem to go and
now it's starting to because it's got 25
years behind it but it you know and the
thing is in hip-hop to like the reason
we be getting it so bad is because then
like a lot of the young rappers will say
dumb ass [ __ ] like you know like Tupac
is wack or something it's just like you
know clearly I understand that if you're
like 16 or whatever you probably never
slap Tupac you know me right I just
don't you know I mean but you gotta have
enough respect I say like you know the
older generation has to have enough like
they have to have enough love in their
heart to let the younger generation do
what they want and then the younger
generation our only job is to at least
pay some what ever
to the people who made this [ __ ]
possible it really I mean and if you if
we can both do that we can all get along
like there's no reason it should be such
a beef but when you say dumbass [ __ ]
like Tupac swagger would ever like well
he got a lot of [ __ ] for a little zing
got a lot of [ __ ] for that and it's only
coming out if you're a rock musician is
saying John Lennon was that was a hack
people John [ __ ] Michael Jackie was D
really spilled the beat his daughter I
think y'all diamond he backed up on a
lot of that stuff because he was really
he really gave a [ __ ] very
controversial interview yeah he outed
everybody yeah it was like deathbed
confession stuff yeah but don't you
think like people like a little Zayn say
stuff like that I'll say the same exact
homos and don't you think that people
like they say stuff like that knowing
the people gonna get super pissed I
think like I mean I don't know dude I
don't know because it's like on one hand
it's like that's probably maybe just how
he feels and I'm not you know I mean
he's also my boy too like right I
understand it like I understand how you
know somebody a younger age from this
generation doesn't listen to that it
never did so in their mind they might
think that [ __ ] is wack but I think just
saying it is like the part where it's
like you know I mean now it's like
you're [ __ ] out people just think you
being a dick you know now yeah you know
I mean cuz it's like there's no need for
you to express a head right you feel me
if you think this legendary person is
wacked like you know I mean there's
probably a lot of kids and never listen
to Aretha Franklin but like why would
you go out of your way to be like man
that shit's whack because it's like that
[ __ ] paved the way for us to do what we
want to do right so that's my advice to
all the younger people is like just pay
homage to the older people and it's like
older people shut the [ __ ] up about the
younger people doing our younger [ __ ]
open these face tattoos I just don't
understand I know but it's like think
about it like if you grew up in the
2000s if you were born in 2000 little
lame for sure has got to be the most
legendary Robert II and have you looked
at a picture of Lil Wayne
he has dreadlocks his face - he's into
like the whole like lien thing right
like it makes total he was a rock star
right it makes total sense I see
everybody is like that he's Gary Oldman
from true romance pretty much hey when
you were a kid to honor to ask you to
your to speech impediment and got
bullied I did man no just I can't hear
I'm talking to you I can't thank you
thank you thank you know what cuz it's
like y'all it just you know I mean we're
just so we're just such good friends
already
are we the to me a gym or that you guys
here for this year that's awesome I went
to I had a lisp which is not an
impediment so I have I have a gnarly I
have a lisp still but I can't hear it I
know Thank You Man thank you um you know
and I think I feel like the more I talk
the more I do interviews and [ __ ] the
better I get at like you know just uh
what's the word enunciate everything
yeah um yeah when I was a kid
um I definitely got bullied all the time
because I just had a gnarly ass list but
I couldn't stop it I went to like the
little speech classes and [ __ ] that
wasn't helping do they tell you to put
your teeth together when you say yes as
I remember going they gave me like a
cork and I had to bite the cork and like
talk and like I literally went to like
speech therapy every single day at my
elementary school and yeah just remember
like not knowing what was wrong you know
I mean that's a weird-ass thing when
you're a little kid you like wait why am
I going to all this special [ __ ] you
know I mean your moms like no it's it's
it's nothing wrong and you find out it's
because you talk funny I guess
right and like just where I grew up like
everybody that went to my school was
either like african-american or like
Latino right Hispanic and I was the only
person that like I had another white kid
at the school his name was Steven shouts
out to Steven middle school and were you
friends with him or did you try to diss
way like everybody that was coming after
you um so Steven guy made fun all the
time and I had a voice like this you
know I mean I talked like my mom it was
just like a white mom
so I white mom voice and I had a lisp so
it's just like I was a very easy target
you know I mean and so it kind of kept
me from like really expressing myself
when I was younger because you can't
express yourself if you never [ __ ]
talk you don't know anything about
yourself right yeah right and so I was
kind of shy and just like
and I would like sing to myself in like
the corner like I was weird oh I was for
sure like weird do people catch you
change yourself
definitely oh no it's even worse mom
voice having a snake over here singing
to himself and I was just an easy target
but then the Opera was it just uh it was
just I never gotta be that good beat up
I got you know I got punched one time in
the bathroom in elementary school that
just sucked the bathroom had to take a
piss have a bad teacher finally let me
go get to the bathroom this kid named
Eddie is in there and Eddie is hell is
smaller than me and Eddie still punched
me hella hard in the stomach and like I
ain't do [ __ ] I remember thinking like
what happened right now I was like I was
thinking about the situation like wait
why didn't I beat this person up have
you walked through that moment over and
over again and why did I allow that to
happen yeah I have any had hella
intimidation factor because he was just
like he you know he people like did a
little my crazy life like hand tap with
yeah hand already this fifth grade right
he's straight ese doubt like he's
already looked harder you don't say this
confident guy and you're sitting there
in the corner singing like your mom
singing like my mom and stuff anything
I'm beating his ass at the bathroom he's
like I go through like he ran there in
JIT got there first it's like right I
see I gotta be chaste for what you're
doing in the class I'm sorry dawg and he
got punched you and yeah you got punch
me I remember thinking like that was a
whack that should happen again
so you got bullied verbally I got
bullied verbally yeah a lot cuz yeah I
mean like I said I was just an easy
target and I wasn't me I'd be making fun
of me too and the bully since you become
famous have the bullies come back and be
like yo that's the only reason I keep
Facebook yeah Facebook is there like not
even the post anything just to monitor
how the bully's lives are going like you
know I mean every like once a night I'll
go on there and just look at me like
yeah that's right that's right you
McDonald's shift manager yeah so they're
not going well a lot of them I'm not man
I think and I think if you were bullying
people when you were younger chances are
you're probably not doing this well yeah
I mean because you focus your whole life
on really capitalizing on what other
people weren't doing and not what you
should be doing if you're a bully you're
trying to focus on people who are doing
bad and you're trying to like make that
even worse you know I mean and if you
are somebody that's full of self love
and all this other awesome [ __ ] you're
gonna spend more time trying to create
something great for yourself when do you
start to make money and through what
means you know I mean I think people who
aren't in your industry the music
industry yeah are kind of like trying to
wrap their head around when you actually
make money how one makes money in this
culture I would say for the majority of
my rap career it really is more like a
minimum-wage job up until like you know
a couple years ago right like you make
enough money to get by you know I mean
you have to go on to her you have to
tour your ass off for sure you gotta try
and get people to sell t-shirts you know
I mean you got it hey buy this t-shirt
with my face on it please yeah man I
would say you end up making money once
you have built like a strong fan base
and they'll do whatever you ask them to
do type [ __ ] yeah I mean but for the
first couple years like if you might as
well be a college kid like you're gonna
be broke touring and stuff like that in
the shirts how do you are you good with
keeping track of of the numbers and what
you should be getting because a lot of
artists get ripped off it's really hard
to keep track of all the the money that
should be coming in yeah definitely but
prior to being a rapper I was a rapper
with hella jobs you know I mean I was
like my first job was advanced shots out
the vans then I worked at like hella
other retail places every single store
in the mall I pretty much worked at and
then I was a gas meter reader for hella
long you go from house to house and read
gas meter - meters and [ __ ] um so I've
always been semi good at like you know I
mean taking care of like my finances and
[ __ ] yeah and so and then once you're in
like in the beginning you have to do
everything yourself
so you know how many t-shirts are in the
box you know how many suck you so you
know I mean you know how broke you're
gonna be at the end of the tour yeah cuz
you're not selling enough you don't mean
the venue's taking 40% and they're
putting on a state tax when you start
doing the paperwork for the straight
merchandise you like what the [ __ ] is
this yeah it's a 40% split 60/40 and
that's a lame
you really hit you with and I'm like
wait but why yeah I'm like wait hold on
I'm bringing the people to this venue
I'm hoping they don't care guys sell it
it's a fine we own the walls like okay
but what if there's nobody here do you
start did you when you have a hit do you
make money off the actual music oh yeah
there's feet in dough once you make a
hit then you make money yeah yeah once
you get a head that's right yeah you
have to work until you get that hit in
you then you make alimony I watched the
movie last night the movies great it's
called the after-party and it's like
it's it's it's the world star movie but
it's it's more it's just a cool movie
because I don't think that the young
hip-hop culture is really represented in
film especially like this because at the
end of the day this is really just like
a young coming-of-age sort of yeah movie
that takes place over like a crazy night
but you just said you worked at vans I
know that you're you're a fan of vans
yeah I am but laughs guy yeah I've as
and maybe it just occurred to me because
I'm a sneaker geek but you're shatter
backboard ones yes
felt to me like a big part of this move
they were they were and I remember why
did you go why didn't you let go like
well why can't I where they Manson it
wouldn't make sense you know like if I
wore vans I might as well my character
name should just be [ __ ] Kyle it's
too much that's right that'd be too true
to the thing even though everything
pretty much was on point my dad actually
is a marine you know blaring the wood
who plays my dad is like a marine in
there right so there's a lot of [ __ ]
that was very accurate but if I were to
rock fans would have been too much and
I'm really happy I didn't because
through this movie I actually ended up
falling in love with Jordans dude like
I've never rocked Jordan's because I
could never afford them shits mm-hmm and
you know I got roasted for having a fake
pair of Jordans brother like lime-green
fives with like the Brad hello fingers
dog like you can see the right you can
see everything it was fake you can see
his fingernails like the shoes turned
this is when you were a kid this way I
did somebody point out that they like
they don't make him in that color or
like bread that color wave off the
texture of the shit's off it's chipping
the paint
is chipping brett has too many fingers
like they went in bro you weren't
embarrassed at all are you how was it
that was it I got over being embarrassed
about [ __ ] when when I hit high school
cuz I was like dude there's no I mean I
was like one I was like I can't change
the things about me that they're making
fun of me about you could change having
fake Jordans you could okay I mean
technically yeah not good I can't
different shoes yeah now I did now I
just went in vans and chucks I mean I
could change it like that but I mean at
the end of the day I noticed like
somebody's because of being made fun of
so early I was blessed to realize that
people's opinions about me do not matter
especially if that person is not helping
me get nowhere in life if you are not
paying me loving me or something like
that your opinion of me is like who
gives you know I mean who cares right
you're right but it's hard to follow
that it's hard to follow that truth
that's all right and it's all right
until you really just start putting
middle fingers up Karen were you also
about even when you start to get a
little bit of success it becomes a
little bit easier yeah to trust yourself
and debility obviously you guys were
wrong
yeah no effects but it takes you know
years of that not being the case okay my
bad sorry fell in love with Jordans yeah
it is a superior shoe that shadow
backboard is incredible it's so soft
like and it was a big part I think
that's the very first thing that was on
the script when describing my character
really Owen shattered backboard one you
know I mean yeah did you read that going
like oh cool I'm against for free
shattered backboards you guys mean oh
it's crazy I didn't I had no clue what
that was
that's so fun I don't know what that is
now as you're saying it's shattered
backboards the name of the show yeah
like the orange Jordan one it's like a
Jordan one and it's like orange black
it's super super popular super limited
they cost like okay yeah they cost like
$700
yeah oh that's my first sneaker you know
why you wouldn't defend that much no I
would not no no it's so the one all the
way to the right to orange in the black
one yeah yeah that's what I had yeah and
um yeah dude that [ __ ] was oh those I
think those are fake too
how could you tell that I don't think
that very deal made one of those yet no
yeah the one to the no II didn't I was
yeah I'm see now I'm good at it and [ __ ]
about no yeah right no no Jordan I can
spot a fake shoe too but it's just you
know you wanna hear something about Jim
hit me Jim if you was it was this
special for Netflix rage Netflix Netflix
baby I'm Jim's Nephilim Jim has Netflix
comedy special come on Kyle yes
put some more Yeezys for the first time
on his Netflix special isn't that right
yeah did Wow did no I'd never own
diesease how do you like him how much
did you have to pay for him I got I
wasn't sure my size and it was last
minute so I bought five pairs whoa and
they were literate huh
I was five I was 100% sure on my
snowboard in five pairs uh-huh I mean
you need 20 something for 29 a pop plus
shipping $29
yeah yeah $20 a pop plus shipping $2,900
no $29 a pop plus shipping though would
you have my connection added he is a
knight but he's made at like like a
school or something they were in China
they were just they came in the typical
Yeezys Bob playing cardboard box he got
him he wore terribly fake 20 29 bucks
it's one of my favorite things I've ever
done it was just to make us laugh he
didn't even acknowledge it on the
special I was just like Jim if you were
they have my picture of Kanye Auto Mike
he then he gave him do his other he's a
very stupid friend of ours named rich
Vaughan he's a real dope but he's very
very stupid but we gave him a pair
because he likes sneakers he's an old
man and so we told him to go to the
sneaker store and sell these nice I told
him I didn't wear them for my special
didn't work you probably get like you
know 1600 for them whatever we told him
and he went to try it it's in a plane
it's in a plain cardboard box with Asian
letters written in ballpoint pen Oh Mike
and so he goes to this knee actually
went out of his way went to the sneaker
store tried to sell him he just put him
up on the counter and immediately the
guys they shoot him or what they do
these are completely think you get him
out of here yeah what I want anything to
do with you yeah these are Negroes
like you can get murdered for doing
something like pulling up with fake
Easy's trying to sell oh yeah I was
really happy for 20 bucks
that's very pleased how many dude that's
insane that's insane yeah that sounds
like the fakest [ __ ] I've ever heard
about